le soulagement de cette femme
lorsqu'elle traverse la frontière et
entre dans l'union européenne
ils sont des dizaines des centaines
d'ukrainiens dans la précipitation ils
fuient leur pays
nous sommes à dos rond aux points de
passage entre pologne et ukraine un peu
plus au sud toujours en pologne 200
réfugiés ont passé la nuit dans cette
gare à quelques kilomètres de la
frontière afl je me sens en sécurité ici
mais je ne peux pas vraiment aider mes
parents et mes amis beaucoup d'entre eux
sont en danger ils n'ont pas pu partir
aussi rapidement que moi
à 5 heures j'ai pris un train ma vie a
complètement basculé en une demi journée
mais je suis heureuse de savoir que nous
avons un endroit où aller
certaines personnes n'ont nulle part où
aller pour se réfugier et cette terrible
combien seront ils doit-on s'attendre à
un exode massif à palanca en moldavie en
moins d'une journée 4000 ukrainiens ont
franchi la frontière
un défi de taille pour les autorités
moldaves qui ont installé en urgence ces
centres d'accueil temporaires
l'union européenne se dit pleinement
préparés à accueillir ces réfugiés la
maison blanche assure que les états unis
restaurant solidaire
nous attendons à ce que la majorité des
réfugiés
vet alliées en europe et dans les pays
voisins donc nous travaillons avec les
pays européens pour déterminer les
besoins et capacités en pologne par
exemple où nous avons vu un flux
croissant de réfugiés au cours des
dernières 24 heures
selon l'onu environ cent mille personnes
ont fui leurs foyers en ukraine gauthier